Let's go to voicemail.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine, two, David P.
here's the voicemail that's sort of funny,
but it relates to something we've been thinking
about.
Take a listen.
Hey David, Joe from California.
Hey, um, have you thought about doing it?
Tour meaning, uh, say you take a month and
you travel to different, um, central areas,
uh, where you have listeners, we, you meet
up, you do a live broadcast show from there
at the same time to maybe a voter registration
drive.
I'll have a live guest there, greet and at
the same time social, some Birch.
So that would be cool.
Have you thought of that?
Hi David.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so I love the idea.
I would love to get to different parts of
the country, including parts of the country.
I don't typically get to meet viewers, do
live shows, all that stuff.
The concerns are more practical.
Number one, the amount of logistics for a
tour.
And now I know people who have done tours,
the logistics are crazy.
So if we were to handle it internally, it
would be almost crippling because of the amount
of stuff that would not get done because we're
dealing with the tour logistics.
So we are, I'm talking to my agent, my agent
came to me a couple of weeks ago actually
and said, Hey, I want to go and talk to an
actual tour management company where they
would set up everything so you don't have
to deal with it.
You would just have to show up.
That would make it much more feasible.
And my manager is actually talking about doing
it.
But some other, uh, progressive hosts that,
whose names certainly you would recognize
that would be very interesting.
The other thing is, you know, taking a month
off from the show is basically a nonstarter.
Doing the show on the road in addition to
events is, um, that's another set of logistics
and the show is best when I'm in the studio.
That's the reality.
I'm not even sure if I'm going to the conventions
this summer because the best show would be
me being here, having reporters there doing
live coverage via video.
Whenever we're at events, I do feel like the
content actually suffers to some degree, so
that's another question.
If we were to do it like a month long tour,
the other possibility is to only do events
around weekends, like Thursday, Friday, Saturday
events, and travel back and forth every week.
That is a big undertaking as well, so we're
looking into the tour thing.
I would love to do it at a personal level.
I think it would be great.
It's the, the devil is in the details as the
kids these days, like to say that does it
for today.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you.
Get instant access by becoming a member or
a patron.
I will speak to you then or on tonight's live
Iowa caucus results stream on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook.
See you then
on the bonus show or just tomorrow if you
want to be [inaudible] the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].